[Musique]
bien
bonsoir c'est le numéro 1 d'une série
qui s'appelle la dernière séance et ce
soir vous allez pouvoir regarder un film
riche en aventure ou en couleur qui
s'appelle le corset rouge le corset
rouge avec bcter mais je vous rassure
tout de suite il n'y aa pas que ça hein
il y aura également des actualités de
l'époque c'est-à-dire 52 il y aura des
dessins animés il y aura un peu plus
tard dans la soirée un autre film
superbe aussi avec Robert mitchou
s'appelle bandido Cabalero alors si vous
voulez bien il s'agit maintenant de
faire un jeu très simple c'està dire
régler vos mondes sur 20h30 et on se
rrouve tout à l'heure pour la dernière
séance car le monde rentre et je prends
les atas
[Musique]
t
amessieurs préparez votre monnaie s'il
vous
plaîtil
pla00 fr s'il vous
plat
place bienvenue à la dernière séance
vous allez voir ce que que
c'était les années 50 voirm autre chose
bien pas prix je pas
d' nous allons voir ensemble plein de
choses fantasti
merveilleuses
monsieur dites-moi rassurez-moi il y a
bien les
actualités les dessins animés
il y a bien les
réclames la semaine prochaine sur votre
écran
il y a bien de grands film
trêve de
plaisanterie nous débons par syvestre
leat dans
vies 45 le cors rouge avec B lcaster
c'est vous dire 22h30 les actualités que
se passe-il dans notre monde 22h40
encore un dessin animé rou détective
22h45 les publicités de l'époque les
réclame donc il entend fait rire 22h50
sur scène
en William W oui
22h55 le journal des les nouvelles et ce
c'est logique 23h5 Robert mitchou dans
bandido Cabalero mais qu'est-ce que
j'entends mais qu'est-ce que j'entends
c'est le dessin
[Musique]
animé
oh bravo oh bravo
Ctait bien hein ah ça ça dore pas ça
c'est formidable ah bah oui bant que je
l'ai fait exprès he je vous dirais je l'
fait exprès parce que c'est un mes
acteurs favoris avec Robert mitchou que
nous verrons tout à l'heure enfin bref
ça m'a fait plaisir j'espère à vous
aussi de revoir le corset rouge pour la
1è fois en ce qui me concerne non et
puis je dois dire que bon bortan
castter on peut en dire du mal un peu
quand même il avait pas de mal lui à
faire ça lui il était trapésiste
évidemment c'est facile facile ce qu'il
fait si j'avais été trapésziste moi si
on m'avait aidé mais non pour revenir
àcastter c'est le trème film qu' faisait
avec robertm en tant que metteur en
scène il faut souligner quand même que
le premier qu'ils ont commis ensemble
qui était les tueurs a fait de B lcaster
du jour du lendemain une vodette premier
film vudette faut le faire quand même le
second
c'était c'était c'était iron cross oui
iron cross pourqui j'ai tué avec Yvon de
Carlo Yvon de Carlo tuit bienvon de Carl
puis al le cors rougeétaé le dernier
sont fâchés paraîtrait même que ce
serait l'enquesteur qui aurait tourné
les derniers
enfin ça Rob Mac ne l'a pas certifié
donc peut-on porter crédit à ce genre de
chose allez donc savoir avec ses acteurs
hein bon bon tout ça pour vous dire
quand même que on va regarder si vous
voulez bien les actualités de 1952 qui
donc sont l'anné du film et puis nous
allons voir un un dessin animé avec
droui droui qui va faire le détective
pour l're plus grande joie des petits et
les grands bien sûr et comme dirait le
roupi et bien Hello
ce qui signifie bonjour joyeux
contribuable cé
bien et attendez pas fini puis que si
vous voulez bien être avec nous le mois
prochain pour la dernière séance vous
verrez la terre des pharaons un film
carrment suivi de le Jour où la Terre
s'arrêta un film de science-fiction
Monsieur Robert W alors sera avec
nous